[音楽]
[拍手]
39歳の春
自宅近くに開店したばかりの絨毯屋で1枚のペルシャ絨毯を購入しました
今はその絨毯を見るたびにめぐりアーシャの不思議さを感じています
1枚のじゅうたんを買ったことで
イランという国に興味を持ちいら映画をよく見るようになりました
当時私は映画を観ることは好きでしたが映画を作るのに何が必要か全く知らず
将来自分が
映画プロデューサーになるとあ
思いもよりませんでした
ではなぜ主婦だった私が
40歳にして映画を作り始めたのか
きっかけは10歳になる娘との約束
あなたを主演に映画をつくってあげるから受けた仕事はやり通しなさいでした
というのも
娘が大でしょうを受け2やが決まった映画の内容がどうにも納得いかず
おまけに制作会社が資金難で劇場公開が危ぶまれていたからです
そこで私は日本とイランの子供たちが主演の映画の構想を練る
日本の大手映画会社に企画の売り込みに行きました
ところがどの会社も
原作がないから無理だよ
子供が映画がヒットしないよ経験がないからダメだ
まったく相手にされません
あ
日本では経験がないと映画部作りが無理なんだなと諦めていた時に
子供が主演のイラン映画運動靴と赤い金魚が
アカデミー賞外国映画賞を受賞したというニュースを聞き
はこれだ
イランの映画会社とだったら私が無名でもなんとかなるかもしれないと思い
翌週にはイランにとんで
イランの有名な監督に映画を一緒に作りましょうとお願いしていました
イランの監督は日本と違って
どういうお話とただそれだけ聞くので
日本とイランの子供が主役で縦軸をペルシャ絨毯に心温まるお話を作りたいと身振り
手振りま
交えながら説得しましたらいいお話だね
楽しくなるをやりましょう
ん
と
いう流れになりそのまで借り契約をして
手付金までおいて日本に戻ってきました
しかし
それからが
悲劇の始まりでした
映画プロデューサーとして大切なことは
物語の骨格を決め
映画監督を決め
制作資金を集め契約を結ぶことです私は
監督はイラン人
制作資金は何とかなったものの契約のところで大変な失敗をしました
事前に弁護士のチェックを受け
双方で合意した契約内容の一ページ
ワールドセールスは日本側にあるという内容がなぜか
イラン側にあると書き換えられていけいたんです
それを見落としてサイン
イラン側が契約寸前に
書類をすり替えていたようなんですね
そうとも知らず日本に戻り配給会社に契約書を見せたら
増田さんなぜ確認しないで3位したんですかこれでは出資できませんと言われてしまい
ました
イラン側はサインしたのはあなたでしょ
3した私が悪いと言います
この契約書が有効になってしまったら
映画はイランのものになってしまう
私はいてもたってもいられず
翌週単身平井に飛びイランがう
制作者に強く抗議しました
するとその上司が出てきて
契約書を作り直してあげるからいくら払えるんだと
こーきました
私は映画を作るために貯金をすべて使った
車も売った家も担保にお金借りました
もう得るものはない
これでは日本に帰れない
と怒りがだんだんだんだん
をこみ上げてきてそのまで持ってきたケープ所全部ビリビリビリビリ破り始めました
そして涙が出てきたんです
ダイラガーはどうして契約書を破るんだ
いやこれは神だから契約書がて連れてきていたら
破れない
と切り返すと
さすがに
泣きながら
家白書をやブルー交渉相手の覚悟を
理解してか
しぶしぶ
契約書を作り直してくれることになりました
今思えば本当に素人だったと思います
その後仲良くなったイラン人からこんなアドバイスをいただきました
人間は
悩めば悩むほど神に近づく
氷見も少しだけ神に近づいたねと
映画風も絨毯は
中東のアカデミー賞といわれるファジル国際映画祭で観客賞を含む3賞を受賞しました
東京ありがとうございます
東京国際映画祭でも特別招待作品となり話題になりました
しかし
映画はヒットしなかったんです
私は
お金を失いました
その時に映画に出演してくださっていた今は亡き
日本の盟友三國連太郎さんからこんなことを言われました
君はイランと映画を作ったことでこれだけの人脈を得てこれだけの経験をしたんだから
この経験をもう1本映画作ってあなたの財産にしないと
財産にしなさいと励まされました
2作目の平成職人の挑戦は私のフル者と
フィラ高山の祭り値の復元にかける職人たちの生き様も描いたドキュメンタリー映画
です
この映画も
当初映画関係者からは職人の映画なんて誰が見るんだ
興行的に大失敗するからやめなさいと耳打ちされました
少し
ガバッ
工業だけがすべてではない
と思い出演してくれた
職人たちに
協力を見て求めたところこのパワーがすごかった
京都から始まった劇場公開は全国に広がり日本の大手ものを創り
ものづくりの企業そして技術系の大学が続々資源支援に回ってくれました
あ
何のために映画を作るんだなという目的がはっきりしていれば
認めてくれるんだなっていうことを第二作目で学びました
日本には
語り部といわれる今日老害て
日本の伝統文化や
先人たちの哲学を語って次の世代に
子どもたちに伝えていましたところが現在は各核家族化になりそうした風習もだんだん
少なくなってきています
そこで私はその語り部の薬を映像にして次の世代に伝えたい
これが私の使命だなと感じるようになりました
最近劇場公開した映画に
さんまとカタールがあります
日本と
イラムとペルシャ湾をはさんで
レッチする中東の国カタール
このカタールとの映画は
2011年
東日本大震災が起きたとき壊滅的な被害を受け復興は不可能だと言われた
さんまで有名な町女川町が若者のエネルギーを結集して復興のトップランナーとなる
までを描いた記録映画です
復興の後押しをしたのはカタールでした
ではなぜカタールが女川町を支援したのでしょう
カタールは今でこそ世界で最も裕福な国となっていますが
1930年代
天然ガスが発掘されるまでは
天然真珠と
漁業を中心とした小さな国でした
その天然ガスを日本の技術と経済支援によってえっか天然ガスにして世界に輸出できる
よう方経済の基盤を作ったのが日本なんです
ですからカタール政府は東日本大震災が起きたときどの国よりも早くいの一番で
カタールフレンド基金をつくり
恩返しの魂への支援をしました
わずか大型冷凍冷蔵庫
これが
カタールからシーンをしてくれた大型冷蔵庫なんです
これです津波対応
施したこの大型冷蔵庫は女川町のシンボルになり
女川は再び3万日本一になるんだっていう夢を人々に与えています
新第1話
生きてる人の心の中に生き続けている
だから生かされている俺たちは熱い
これは映画に登場してくれたを長い長の皆さんの言葉です
この姿を世界に発信したいそして
カタールだけではなく日本は東日本大震災が起きたとき世界
移住からいろんな支援を受けました映像を通してその感謝を伝えたい
これは映画を持つ映画の持つ力だと思います
映画製作
初めは素人でしたが
15年もこの教会で働いているとジャンガンの前が知られるようになり
いろんな企画が持ち込まれるようになりました
細菌性同一性障害
gpt を扱った映画を製作し
は以来になり劇場公開しました
ハイヒール革命です
この映画も当初大手の映画会社からは
企画が却下された作品です
映画はもちろんロマンは大切です
しかし最後はそろばんなんです
映画
お金をどう集めどう使っていくかが大切なんです
ですから出資してくださローとしている皆さんには
お金は
墓場まで持っていくことはできません
映画の9分強で
お金を返しできないかもしれませんがあなたの名前とその思いは映画の中にえいえんに
残ります
ですから私と
楽しく遊びながら映画作りをしませんか
と微笑みかけながら
今まで
たくさんの方に協力いただきながら十数本の映画を作ることができました
ありがとうございプレシィ
私の映画製作は
思いを共有する皆さんと夢は大きく
志は高く
仕事は楽しくがモットーです
たまにはヒットしてもらいたいと思いも思いますが
大切なことは人々の思いを映像にして次の世代に伝えることです
そして
[音楽]
100年先まで残る現代の飾りべとなりたいんです
これからの映画製作皆さんの心に残る
映画を全身全霊
作り続けていきたいとおもいますありがとうございます
[拍手]